hey everyone this is sarah with
registered nurse RN comm and today i'm
going to show you how to give an
injection in the ventral gluteal muscle
here I have Miss Smith
she is our mannequin and we're going to
give her an injection in the side first
what you want to do is you want to get
your patient on their left or right side
Miss Smith is on her left side so we get
her prepped for that and you draw up
your medication you do hand hygiene and
what you do the key to giving these
injections is finding your landmarks and
it's very important you know what
landmarks to look for when giving these
injections in the muscle because you
want to avoid nerves and any great
vessels so for the ventral gluteal we
are going to find our great trochanter
so we have her on her left side so we're
going to take our hand closest to the
patient and we're going to put our palm
on the great trick canter so about right
there then you're going to take your
index finger and you're going to point
it towards the anterior superior iliac
spine which is about right there then
you're gonna take your three fingers and
put them together and keep your middle
your index finger straight and you're
gonna form a little V and in between
that V is where we're gonna go for our
injection so keep your hand like that
take your alcohol prep and clean the
side very well any germs in a circular
motion for about three to five seconds
you're going to get your injection I
like to take my cap off I'm in between
my fingers and you're gonna go in at a
90 degree angle
okay course your aspirate because it is
in the muscle you wanna make sure you're
not any vessels you aspirate when you
have
but that's a good sign and then you're
going to inject hold it there just for a
second to let all that get in there and
you're going to take out and engage your
safety on your needle and just put a
little gauze or band-aid over to prevent
any bleeding and that is how you give an
injection in the Ventura gluteal muscle
next be sure to check out my video on
how to give an injection in the dorsal
gluteal muscle or the deltoid thank you
so much for watching and if you like
this video please share it with your
friends and be sure to visit my website
register nurse RN com